this morning we're hearing from an
oklahoma girls basketball team that was
called the n-word by a sports announcer
who was calling the game and he said
that into a live microphone
as a team took a knee during the
national anthem at a high school
tournament game
national correspondent jerica duncan
reports on the young woman
young women rather who are now state
champions
we never would have thought like wow
this would happen to us
kalyn simmons shantae embry and millie
roberts say their team was in shock when
their coach
shared the news it was just like blank
stares
the norman high school girls basketball
squad had taken a knee during the
national anthem
all season in an effort to bring
awareness to racism and social injustice
but on thursday
[Music]
an open microphone captured sports
announcer matt rowan berating them
with a racial slur it just goes to prove
the point
that this is why we took a knee in a
statement the nfhs network which
broadcast the game
promised an investigation saying that it
cut ties with the third party crew
involved
and adding that it firmly condemns
racism hate
and discrimination rowan did release an
apology but blamed the rant on his type
one diabetes writing
i do not believe that i would have made
such horrible statements
absent my sugar spiking just real ugly
civil rights attorney mike lowe and ben
crump are representing the team
we're demanding that the regulatory
authorities
of the sports and athletic
high school association in oklahoma
publicly
condemn this racism and the tigers
the girls took home a state title
saturday celebrating one win
now fighting for something bigger we
just want change within
our community our state and our country
and that change is going to start with
people holding holding other people
accountable
you are absolutely right about that the
oklahoma secondary schools activities
association
which oversaw the basketball tournament
released an apology as well
they have also cut ties with rowan
saying this kind of behavior will never
be tolerated
they promised to make further comments
pending an investigation
i keep thinking about all the people
that actually have type 1 diabetes
saying don't lump us in with yours
that is not a side effect i know racism
racism is not a side effect of type 1
diabetes
not in any medical journal yeah very
rich to come up with that as an excuse
although at the end of the day we'll say
congratulations on the stage yes exactly
way to turn that around tony